hello my name is jason sondenberg
i'm part of the wolfram alpha chemistry
team
and i'd like to share with you today
some of the efforts that we've been
doing in chemical education
and is the talk is titled the chemical
education with wolfram technologies
as many of you may know we have quite a
few
technologies from the wolfram stack for
chemical education
there are four that i'm going to talk
about today namely wolframalpha the
demonstrations project wolfram language
and the wolfram outlook notebook edition
i will touch just briefly on some of the
developments in chemistry in the wolfram
language
uh but you should stay tuned to the talk
immediately following this
by my colleague jason biggs he will be
explaining
in more detail the the latest
developments in the wolfram language
um and so i'll focus on the primarily on
the other three
over the next uh half hour
so what have we been doing it's been a
busy year for
chemical education with wolfram tech and
i'd like to share some of the things
that we've been putting out so
to get things started we kicked this the
year off
with a four-part blog series hopefully
some of you saw
where we were talking about how to use
the step-by-step solutions
aspect of the wolfram alpha
pro package to to solve chemical
reaction problems to do
solutions to work with structure and
bonding and quantum chemistry
and those four blogs are available here
uh if you're
a reader of medium they're also being
cross-posted over to the
teaching with technology blog over there
so if you haven't seen them
those are rolling out we've got two
cross-posted there currently
but the the information there it walks
both
the students and the users through how
to use the technology
what it looks like and how to take
traditional homework problems
and reformulate them into something that
you can feed to wolfram alpha
so if you are looking to get your
students or your colleagues
involved with our tech in their
classroom or their learning space
you might point them to these blogs to
get started to see what we can do
in real in real time so besides adding
more information on how to use the
technology and trying to
build tutorials to to get your students
up to speed without having to
waste learning space time uh to explain
it
we've also been expanding our coverage
so this time last year we had another
graphic that looked very similar
and we've had quite a few developments
since the last
wtc most notably we have three new
content areas so we've now
expanded our coverage into the
equilibrium into the area of kinetics
and the general aspect of molecules
in the chemical conversions which is a
quite popular feature
that we have we've added molar aliquots
and we're hoping to expand the
aliquot support that we have going
forward over the next year
we've in equilibrium we now can take for
a chemical reaction if it's balanceable
and not a fragmented chemical reaction
but if it's fully balanceable then we
can spit back the equilibrium constant
and the reaction quotient
those teaching high school or you know
high school or chemistry in the middle
school curriculum
probably won't be dealing with reaction
quotients but we have support for both
of it so that
it cuts across the entire curriculum
whether you're at the beginning stage
or quite late say maybe taking p chem at
a college level
likewise with kinetics we can now build
the rate of reaction
and the rate of conversion for
the molecules this sort of piggybacks on
the molecule development
in the wolfram language we now have
support for atom count electron count
and proton count
and lastly in our quantum chemistry
section we've expanded our
support for orbital diagrams sometimes
called aufbau diagrams
and we've also got support for
determining valence electrons from the
electron configuration string
so let's go see uh an example of this
and actually show some of the features
so i'm going to start with the
equilibrium constant because that
definitely appears in the high school
curriculum it may not appear much at all
in the
grade school or middle school curriculum
but it's it's a nice thing
to start with to try and show how we can
support not only high school and middle
school folks but also
well up into the college level as well
so here
the query which is linkable here is we
start with
lead chloride going to lead to
cation and the chloride anion
and what we see is that our step by
steps
we always in our first step we restate
the problem
uh to make sure that the student
understands what's going on
uh we introduce in this case the
variable that we're dealing with
the equilibrium constant so in this case
represented by k
then all of our chemistry steps in the
second step have some sort of plan
this mirrors much of the pedagogy and
current
textbooks so we and we
set up a framework for students so that
they can not only see how to get through
this current problem
but also to have a toolbox of frameworks
to
tackle general problems of this type
when they encounter them again
we then start off by balancing the
chemical equation this is
a fully clickable on the live website
and you would get more details i'm not
going to show that here
today step four then we go on and here
we assign stoichiometric numbers again
we are
very cognizant of always introducing
variables for the things that
we are talking about so that the
students not only connect the name
to the variable but they get used to the
notation that they might see in the
chemical literature or in their
textbooks
and so here we grab the balance
coefficients from step three we tabulate
them
and then we follow the instructions for
determining
uh the stoichiometric numbers
in step five then we go on and we
assemble the activity expressions
now if you're in an introductory course
you
would just learn that all solids have an
a term that's one
or for aqueous species it's just the
concentration
but we have details to dig further
so that we can support the the folks
that might be taking pchem
or the introductory student that's
curious as to why in the world is this
just one
um if it wasn't covered in their
particular textbook we'll come back to
looking at
the details of this in just a moment so
we have that that ability to dig deeper
and then uh in step six i'm quite proud
to report that the equilibrium constant
is um
the logic is smart enough to determine
uh what sort of
subscript should be on the the k if
you're in the concentration
basis if you're in the pressure basis if
you are in this case a solubility
product
we know this information based on the
states of matter that are coming through
and were passed to us so when students
are working with
the uh the the tool if they pass us more
information we actually do utilize that
last week we put together the expression
and
uh return the answer so as i said before
we've got support for the upper level or
more curious students for what's going
on with these activity expressions
and the idea here is that you can click
there and get more detail so let's click
on the lead chloride
which has a value of one and what the
student would see
is more details provided and it talks
about how to construct the activity
expression
and here is completely rigorous to the
pecan standards of what's going on we
walk the student through the gory
details
introducing all of the appropriate
symbology
and explain uh why it goes to one and
why we're raising it to a particular
power
likewise for the chloride ion since it's
aqueous
rather than being solid we have a again
a fully
phase dependent description of what's
going on and we walk through the full
expression
with all the [ __ ] details again if the
student is not interested in this or
don't need to worry about it they just
simply don't click on it but we have it
there for
support across the curriculum
i don't know why that's there okay
so what else have we been working on
besides adding new content areas and new
topics that we support we've been
enhancing the
the details that we already have
and let's let's go through that so in
chemical reactions you may have noticed
uh this is already live on the website
uh our layout for chemical equations has
now changed we use a column
format where the name and state of
matter is
underneath it uh it gives a little
better layout
we've changed some of the font colors
and whatnot to make it clearer
in our dilution calculator when we
introduce the equation we now have a
step-by-step support for the full
derivation of this expression so
many times students forget delusions or
get confused
if they want to see where the equation
came from to potentially
learn that process themselves rather
than just simply memorizing
they can now click and see full details
on that we hope to expand
this sort of from first principles
derivations in our calculators and
elsewhere
in the chemistry step-by-step support
going forward
we also did a major overhaul of our
solution preparation
so if you didn't know it you can ask
alpha how to create particular solutions
so you can in if we want something based
on the molarity equation
such as this you can just ask for um
if you want 0.8870 molar sodium chloride
uh we'll show you how to go figure it
out and that you need to dissolve this
much
sodium chloride to a final volume of one
liter
we also know how to um prepare say if
you wanted to prepare from scratch
concentrated hydrogen hydrogen fluoride
of course this would be a little bit
much
much more tedious but we we can handle
those sorts of queries and understand
concentrated
as an adjective for the molarity that's
automatically converted
if we're doing solution preparation from
a dilution
such as in this case for decimal or
acetic acid the
the software already knows that acetic
acid has a concentrated version that's
available commercially
and we use that uh as a
starting point to do a dilution to
prepare the the solution that's required
likewise you can also tell alpha what
aliquot to start with
to then uh do the full dilution to get
down to the desired
concentration so all that is
live and available today
since many of us in the chemical
education community are now doing things
remotely i'd like to highlight some of
the features
that we have in the wolfram
demonstrations to help
build your remote laboratory experiences
or just for uh
have more
engagement with a particular topic so
the wolfram demonstrations projects is
ever growing and has a rather
large group of uh chemistry related
activities uh the team at the
compute2learn team
over at uh in the university of michigan
has been uploading quite a few of these
and that team has been growing uh we
have an example here from
lafayette college chemistry students
under the supervision of professor
hendrickson
they've been creating these are
student-driven student-created
activities at least at lafayette that
are then used to
simulate activities and homework
problems and
laboratory activities and as you can see
you can change the wavelength
that you're doing the measurement at and
whether you're at lambda max
or not it changes the the results
and you can change the concentration and
this uses stimulated data
so one could easily build activities
around this classic near's law
experiment
so that the student could interact with
simulated data
and interact with the experiment at home
without having to come into the
laboratory
and this is just one of many uh
demonstrations that could be utilized in
this way to either expand a homework
problem or a series of classroom
activities
or to support the development of
remote laboratory activities during the
pandemic
speaking of uh the pandemic with using
textbooks a lot of the current textbooks
are starting to move in a way
uh that differs a little bit from some
of the
traditional print textbooks so here we
have chemistry life the universe and
everything more commonly known
in the in the community is the clue
textbook this is by cooper and
klimkowski and what they've done
is they've got a rather streamlined book
that uh takes the perspective
of many of the newer books that there
are some topics
that just having a lot of text in a
chapter doesn't help to explain well
and so they feel that those topics um
are best
taught and experienced and understood
through a lot of interactive activities
and to be uh frank we couldn't agree
more
and have built quite a bit of support
for some of those uh so i'd like to go
through
the topics that the clue textbook this
is the clue general chemistry textbook
so this is
targeted towards a introductory
college-level textbook but the concepts
uh are ones that you would see in an ap
chemistry course or
a standard high school chemistry course
so let's see so they start off as many
of us do when we're teaching
chemistry with energy frequency and
wavelength conversions and we have
calculators for that
where you can go from the energy or the
frequency and we have step-by-step
support for that conversion along with
the frequency and wavelength conversion
using the appropriate calculators
when introducing electronic
configurations as you're introducing the
periodic table
and and the um orbital the orbitals that
the electrons go in we have
support for electron configurations and
short electron configurations
right now we don't have step-by-step
support for this but that will be coming
over the next year
hopefully uh sooner than that
when teaching about valence electrons
it is often useful to have a pictorial
representation using
the so-called alpha diagrams or orbital
diagrams where we have
each orbital represented as a square
with
arrows showing the the electron count
we have step by step support for fully
deriving these things and building them
up
we also have support for the valence
electrons
counting them building it from the short
electron configuration that one gets
here and then
determining the valence electrons
for lewis structures usually the next
topic after you've
gotten comfortable with atoms you now
start stringing them together in
structure
and we have full support for lewis dot
structures for both inorganic complexes
like nitrogen dioxide
or more complicated organic species that
you might get at the end of an
introductory course or at the beginning
of your organic chemistry course
stoichiometry is central to all of
chemistry
courses and day-to-day laboratory
activities for that matter
and we have again full support for this
step-by-step
when you pass us information in this
case we've been given how much
of the starting reagent and how much of
the product so then we can therefore
we can compute the theoretical yield and
percent yield
and this all comes out in tabular form
the stoichiometry
is currently going undergoing an
overhaul so we hope to have a
new and improved version of this uh in a
year from now
but um we still have current step by
steps uh right now
after the introduction to stoichiometry
many
courses introduce oxidation numbers in
the context of redox reactions
and we have full support for determining
oxidation states of a particular
individual species we also have support
for
returning the half reactions and the
reductant and the oxidant
we don't yet have step-by-step support
for that but that's on the docket for
this next year
as i said earlier connect our kinetic
support is brand new this year and
as i said if you pass in an equation
that can be balanced
as in case in this case with thionyl
chloride and the sulfite anion
or over here we have the gaseous
reaction of
chlorine and fluorine then we can build
up the rate of reactions
or the rate of conversion and we have
full step-by-step support for that
and are clear to point out what sort of
assumptions were made along the line
again in supporting our more advanced
courses that they may be worried about
such things which gets
shuffed under the rug in the
introductory courses
our thermochemistry is on the docket for
next year we already support uh
reaction thermodynamics for balanced
chemical equations
we will be adding step-by-step support
for this to show how to do the math
uh in more detail than is currently
given and we also
have added this year the heat transfer
reaction for doing specific heat
calculations
that are also commonly introduced in
thermode the thermochemistry
modules in in various courses lastly i'd
like to
point out uh the other new topic that we
had the equilibrium
again this is a topic that the clue
textbook
views as well suited for just problem
sets and teaching offline rather than
having a big blurb in a textbook
and we now have support for equilibrium
constants and again the logic is smart
enough to figure out in this case here
we have the disassociation
of water and it notices that and returns
a kw appropriately and explains it all
with the step by steps
and likewise for our more advanced
courses that are working with reaction
quotients we have that
here and again the logic is smart enough
to realize that we're in the
concentration basis
and appends the symbology accordingly
lastly i'd like to point out uh what
we've been taking
uh and working up with the wolfram alpha
notebook folks
is that we've been trying to take all
these great step-by-step and will from
alpha support and bring it over to the
wolfram
alpha notebooks which i think is going
to become the
premier way of doing chemistry in the
uh in the wolfram area so
if you'll notice here we i have wolf
from alpha notebook input cells
and so i'm just going to evaluate those
and so you can put this is again the
wolfram alpha notebook what's cool is
that you can just do
conversational english here and and it
understands what's going on
so if the student i need a periodic
table uh
then what you'll get back is just that a
full periodic table
you have control to get you can control
the
interpretation if it didn't quite
understand your query and you can
immediately pop over the full from alpha
results if you want
but now this periodic table is right
here ready for the student to utilize
while they're solving
their particular problem or activity and
what's nice about the wolfram alpha
notebook edition compared to just
wolfram
alpha is that you can now say things
quite colloquially as show me the
structure of a particular molecule
in this case dexamethasone and what you
get back
is the structure diagram and while
that's helpful because uh the 2d
representation of molecules
is is one way that we communicate
structure
most of us need to think about things in
three dimension
and with wolfram alpha notebooks you can
immediately utilize the
molecule 3d plot 3d aspects
and just say display the molecule plot
stick plot and space filling plot and
see the three different common
representations of molecules
and they are fully interactable they
they're rotatable
um write live in your notebook for your
students so your students can both
visualize
and 2d in 3d side by side they can
rotate
right there in their notebook in the
problem that they're working on
and they can see how we you know you can
have conversations about the different
representations and why one is
useful in some cases and not in the
others and really dig deep into these
you know basic chemistry concepts
you can also immediately get access to
the step-by-step support for various
things so in this case
uh we had the orbital diagram that i
pointed out earlier being
a new feature this year and you just so
show steps for
whatever the the concept is in this case
uh
what you get back are your sort of usual
step-by-step steps and you can just show
show all of them right away and again we
see live the student gets the plan
of all the gory details of what what to
do to build up these sorts of problems
you get the
uh the data we also have you know graphs
and pictures to help explain the concept
so here's your standard mandalung
diagram
and the student then is walked through
building up the
the orbital diagram lastly i'll leave
you with an example of
our unit conversions which we have
step-by-step support for
so again you just request step-by-step
support and sure enough
you can get all the steps for working
through the problem
doing all the dimensional analysis which
is laid out in the traditional fraction
forms
so that the the student can follow along
and so i i'm very excited to to show you
the the wolfram alpha notebook edition
like i said i i think it's going to be
the preeminent way that
chemistry is done uh and taught with in
the wolfram language
system um and i'm hoping that you'll
take
time to check it out lastly i will walk
you through all these but
there are quite a bit of chemistry
resources in the wolfram universe and
i've tried to summarize these here for
you
we have a wide variety of tutorials for
getting yourself your colleagues and
your students up to speed on
our technology particularly helpful are
the
quick takes for interacting with wolfram
alpha
then we i've summarized some of the
education support we again
links to the demonstrations for
chemistry our essays in the notebook
archive
and some links to current literature
that's come out in the last few years
showing how
our technology can be used in real life
learning spaces in the chemistry
environment and then i've got links to
the
other support for our language the
wolfram function repository all these
new functions by our team and other
practicing chemists along with
links to other support and with that
i'd like to thank you for your attention
and answer any questions before we all
head over to
jason's talk after this
okay so if you haven't been to a talk i
understand
that if you have a question you need to
raise your hand so that i can then
unmute you and we can chat if not
um i guess we can end here and move over
to the other
uh upcoming chemistry talk at 9 30.
jason there was a question in the chat
on the particle site
i see that thank you uh so the question
is polymers do not appear in your talk
are they not expected to be part of the
subject at wolfram technologies
uh no that's not true we do have support
for polymers and wolfram alpha
we have not done anything new with
polymers at the moment
but they there is some support for it
and i'd be
interested in hearing how what sort of
support we can add in the future
uh or what would be useful in the
classroom for teaching poly
polymers so that's that's where we are
with that
i should just point out if you are
already using
the wolframalpha technology the step by
steps or
the molecule package in wolfram
please don't be shy use the feedback
forms to send suggestions that you might
have either today or
in the future we're always looking for
feedback and
would love to hear what you would like
to see the tech do and
new directions that it should be going
in
well if there aren't any more questions
i'd like to thank you again for coming
and encourage you to stick around
to the next talk at 9 30 by jason
my colleague jason biggs he'll be
explaining more details
of the new features that are in the
molecule package
in the wolfram language